si bernard sand et venez avec un thé qui
raconte son itinéraire des premières
galères aux oeuvres planétaire l'une à
thouars pour me regarder la part d'un
narbonnais bonsoir comme armand tu as
wihr et le dès qu'ils avaient la femme
de bernard pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
mais
et c'est ma maman voulait m'appeler
bernadette après c'est peut-être un
petit peu pour salman est comme une
petite fille pendant deux trois ans et
elle m'a botté des couettes et tout ça
et puis et puis le jour où j'ai compris
quelque chose qu'elle ait pas j'ai
peut-être une coupe et le vélo dès
couper le lien des revers de suite
je vais bien je vais bien je joue c'est
en tout cas ce qu'ils voulaient quand a
commencé à très jeune je fais ta ta
première exposition salon pechiney
j'avais dix ans c'était quoi elle s'est
alors déchaîné le second défi mais moi
je suis le saint-auban dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence et la bayanne
usines pechiney y avait une usine
pechiney qui faisait chaque année un
salon dans le nord il invitait tous les
gens qui étaient un petit peu un peu
artiste ray nous permettez d'exposer
notre travail à paris et c'est là que
pour la première fois et je vais montrer
des premiers tableaux l'enfant départ ce
que c'était et ses paysages comme à mais
regardez bien une attention alors en
1963 c'est bien plus sérieux tu reviens
d'algérie et fait la guerre oui j'ai ouï
oui puisque c'était en 62 ans fait brent
a perdu un truc tu rentres d'alger a été
à nice et tu passes devant un tas de
charbon de chez moi c'est la légende
sais pas si c'est vrai et dans ce coup
tout tombe en arrêt devant ce tas de
charbon et tu décides de faire des
sculptures en forme de tas de charbon
sans forme spécifique d'ailleurs c'était
l'estac exactement là c'est la
définition précise et bien oui mais je
faisais les tableaux tous loin l'époque
où je couvrais complètement là la
surface du tableau avec du noir ce qui
était du goudron et un jour en fait que
j'ai vu la réalité c'est une c'est un
tas de gravier mélange bien du louvre on
s'était laissera prendre l'exemple des
cantons où il s'appelait monsieur bon
duo si je devais faire des sculptures
voilà exactement ce que je devrais faire
et pour des raisons pratiques j'ai fait
avec du chant alors ça a été exposé à
beaubourg
ce
ce charbon ce tas de charbon en 64
l'ouverture c'est quand il ya eu une
exposition d école de nice j'imagine et
entre temps ça avait été acheté en 72
par un dénommé guichard héritiers de
casino mais ce qui est très intéressant
et pourquoi je t'en parle c'est qu'en
fait le taille c'est pas le tas c'est
l'idée que tu vas en fait non exactement
pas le tas qui se déplacent exactement
qu'il remplace tu as raison tu as raison
il à lui ce qu'il a ce qu'il est les
propriétaires en vérité d'une une photo
qui montre le tas de charbon etc signé
la date exactement
et puis chaque fois qu'on expose quelque
part il est exposé à lyon n'y a pas très
longtemps en allemagne ça bouge beaucoup
il est toujours exposé que paris
eh bien on a refait un autre qui ont
détruit c'est vrai en 66 tu pars à new
york avec ton pote armand qui avait
connu à nice bien entendu et là tu
commence à peindre des trucs ça devient
de plus en plus simple et compliqué à la
fois des diagrammes mathématiques des
symboles graphiques et alors injurié une
exposition organisée par der spiegel et
tous les tableaux sont volés c'est
terrible sertissage sasaki beatles
assistent au très saint louis à presque
tous les tableaux ont été volés sauf les
tiers exerçant comme exactement vers
6000 explique assez importante il y
avait des grandes expositions de dessins
et il y avait des oeuvres de raoul
hilberg de darnand de tout le monde tous
les noms on avait mis deux deux oeuvres
qui étaient des écrits des choses très
difficiles conceptuel un matin ils sont
arrivés à la galerie tout a disparu sauf
10h05
les voleurs n'ont pas compris c'est pas
pour ça que tu étais arrêté deux pas
dans 69 n'a pas démoralisé
mais tu t'es ait quand même mais je me
suis arrêté mais pour encore une fois
pour des raisons théoriques je voulais
faire le travail un petit peu plus
réflexive et c'était prévu c'était déjà
prévu quatre ans elle avance que je
l'avais verbale qui dit exactement voilà
je voulais au lieu de nous faire des
oeuvres physique vous pouvez acheter
qu'on ne pouvait collectionner je
voulais expliquer un petit peu les
raisons pour lesquelles j'avais fait
tout ce travail c'est devenu prof à la
sorbonne
voilà j'ai enseigné la balle mais
pendant six ans et est reparti en 76
avec la ligne alors pourquoi tu as
choisi de la ligue
eh bien d'abord parce que parce que ce
sont en fait ces lignes que j'avais de
briser qui sont des angles ou bien des
arcs bien des diagonales qui sont
toujours qui appartient toujours au
vocabulaire mathématiques alors je
voulais rester un petit peu dans cette
ligne dans cette dans cette direction là
mais en donnant à mes oeuvres une
dimension plastique données j'essaie à
ce moment là alors que mon travail
antérieures avaient été très théorique
très très dur il y avait tout d'un stick
de beau à voir
celle ci je voulais qu'elle rentre en
compétition avec des oeuvres de kevin
roberge bédard en fait je voulais faire
de la peinture et des lignes droites des
lignes courbes des lignes indéterminées
c'est quoi une ligne avait sa venue un
petit peu après et bien c'est parce que
je détermine est toujours mais
mes dessins donc des arquets les angles
en disant c'est un angle de 90° 92
degrés et les harkis si elle cite suite
et dénis indéterminée bien elles sont
très libres alors je les appelais
indéterminée parce qu'elles ne sont pas
déterminer mathématiquement voilà c
c'est une question de contexte certains
grands projets qui me fascine et qui est
fascinant c'est ce projet à 140 km de
paris dans une commune il s'appelle land
use entre nemours et auxerre tu veux
faire quoi leur explique que je vais
faire une sculpture comme pour en
produire d'elle que c'est la plus grande
sculpture au monde par exemple la statue
de la liberté sur internet l'arc de
triomphe à l'intérieur
et et tout le flot des voitures d'europe
passeront de danse
oui c'est ça c'est un demi-cercle et
remonte de chaque côté de l'autoroute
d'un côté ça fait cinquante trois mètres
et l'autre côté 15 m voilà c'est une
grande chose voilà comment ça
s'appellera l'arc majeur et puis on
donnera le nombre de degrés qui 295 dire
que le 4° bas et précis
toujours pour être mathématiques bien
sûr alors c'est en acier c'est en acier
ce sera vide à l'intérieur ils vont pour
a fait remonter une personne de jusque
là oh oui oui ça vaut 4 millions de à
peu près non un peu plus en avance que
ça aurait coûté un petit opus parce
qu'avec l'inflation ces quatre niveaux
d'il ya trois ans maintenant
qui va payer qui va payer eh bien le
les autoroutes est là et ça fait deux
erreurs en appel et puis le ministère de
la culture
et puis il y aura un petit peu de
mécénat c'est vrai qu'à un moment quand
c'était trop cher
et toi tu en avais dit non ça va faire
que 48 mètres lui de 53 et tu étais prêt
hypothécaire en loft à new york
oui ça étonnant parce qu'on pense
toujours que les artistes comme ça il
vit sur le dos du ministère de la
culture des sociétés d'autoroutes mais
c'est beau quand même un moment tu étais
prêt à faire ça oui on voulait tant
qu'elles sont toutes façons je vais te
dire j'aurais ainsi pourrait
certainement créé par gilbert c'est
important peu je crois que j'ai déjà
investi beaucoup d'ailleurs dans ce
projet là mais non mais je voudrais
pendant l'offre parce que maintenant
c'est un petit peu mieux qu'à l'époque
il ya trois ans que j'aurais dû le
vendre aujourd'hui je pense que j'avais
très bien s'entendre et l'histoire de
l'australie c'est quoi la avait ça c'est
le nouveau projet alors bien sûr c'est
d'abord une fois que j'en parle ça
jamais non jamais jamais jamais parlé
dans la presse c'est un projet qui c'est
une sculpture qui commencerait en france
sur cette partie du globe disons de la
terre et qui se terminerait dans un
prolongement comme ça en australie est
d'ailleurs aussi en ascom éclatement
donc il ya un petit bout ici puis un
petit blouson exactement exactement et
calculer très mathématiquement pour ça
se termine mais très précisément ça va
se passer c'est bien c'est certain
treize ont été influencés par qui
pourrait vu comme ça eh bien écoutez je
vais te dire si j'avais été trop
influencée je ne serais pas ici on parle
tant aujourd'hui je vais pas ce plaisir
oui tout l'idée c'est que justement on
n'y a pas de doute qu'on appartient à un
contexte historique ont aussi si j'étais
né il ya deux siècles je ne ferai pas ce
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui mais mais
malgré tout j'ai trouvé
disons une direction qui était la mienne
passé personnel à partir du moment où
j'ai utilisé les mathématiques et puis
est proche et matam
vous venez de moins en moins de
canadiens déterminer maintenant je
prends je prends pas ma liberté
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs l'exposition qui
en revanche est en place et très opposés
à la vigne
mathématiques on peut voir ça ou ans
commenté zavala et bien à la galerie
templon j'expose des dessins je propose
des dessins ou des dessins qui font
promettre sur quatre tracés à peu près
écoute ça tourne dans les cinquante
mille dollars
tu serais qui si tu étais pas bernar
venet alors comme comme peintre je crois
que je serais mort
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible